ты получишь всё когда ты поймёшь Это
почему важно посмотреть это видео в
результате просмотра этого видео вы
поймёте как достигать своих целей
гораздо быстрее и легче и не потратите
на это годы своей жизни я пришёл к этому
благодаря своему многолетнему опыту в
бизнесе и благодаря тому что я набил
кучу шишек в своей жизни и а столкнулся
со со многими трудностями Сейчас я вам
расскажу несколько секретов которые
очень важно знать для того чтобы
достигать любых своих целей если вы
будете это знать то я вам гарантирую что
вы потратите в разы меньше усилий и
гораздо быстрее будете достигать своих
целей основная проблема всех людей в том
что когда они что-то хотят они ставят
цели после того как они ставят цели
некоторые планируют некоторые не
планируют но они сразу же начинают
действовать Ну есть конечно категория
людей которые не действуют и
соответственно они никогда ничего не
достигают дело в том что я видел много
людей
которые достигали своих целей даже не
осознавая или не зная как это делать но
я ни разу не видел людей которые знали
как это делать но не делали и достигали
то есть действие является важнейшим
условием достижени любой цели все люди
живут в парадигме такой что если ты
чего-то хочешь обязательно надо что-то
делать но проблема в том что вы не
живёте в вакууме Вы живёте в мире
динамичном мире который каждый день
меняется Круг вас куча других людей у
которых свои интересы свои хотелки свои
желания у меня по этому поводу есть
концепция движение которые я так её
назвал для того чтобы легче понимать из
чего Она состоит Дело в том что когда вы
находитесь в этом мире вы оказываете на
этот мир воздействие В чём оно
проявляется вот даже предположим вы
сидите сейчас где-нибудь на диване Сидя
на диване вы оказываете давление на
диван вы продавливается диван вы
занимаете чьё-то место и это кому-то
нравится или не нравится даже ничего не
делая вы оказываете воздействие на этот
мир ваше воздействие на этот мир
автоматически вызывает три силы Первое -
это противодействие это силы которые
прямо направлены против вашего действия
это ещё по-моему второй или третий закон
Ньютона на любую направленную силу
действует противоположно направленная а
сила а такая же сила это даже физика
подтверждает поэтому любое ваше
воздействие на этот мир вызывает силу
противодействия это первая сила второе
любое ваше действие или воздействие на
этот мир вызывает силу содействия это те
силы которые содействуют вам Ну давайте
возьмём так на примере чтобы было совсем
понятно вы собрались идти в кино с
друзьями может оказаться Так
что жена будет против она может сказать
Нет давай лучше сегодня пойдём с
подругами или там там семьёй поужинаем
Вот вы вызвали силу противодействия в то
же время у вас могут быть силы
содействия дети могут кричать ура ура
папа пошли в кино классная идея Таким
образом у вас появилась сила содействия
и есть третья сила - это сила
взаимодействие она как правило
нейтральна это Например могут быть Ваши
родители которые с улыбкой наблюдают на
то как вы обсуждаете Куда пойти Когда вы
идёте к своей цели Вы должны учитывать
эти силы противодействия силы содействия
и силы взаимодействия и при этом силы
противодействия всегда будут чтобы чтобы
вы не делали силы содействия тоже всегда
будут основная борьба всегда
разворачивается за перетягивание на свою
сторону силы взаимодействия или
нейтральные силы вот в этом случае или
примере который я вам привёл Если вы
сможете перетянуть родителей на свою
сторону то ваша жена примет ваше решение
Итак учитывайте Каждый раз когда ставите
себе цели учитывайте вот эти три силы
которые всегда появляются Когда вы
ставите или хотите достичь чего-то или
возьмём другой пример Дело в том что ко
мне приходит очень много молодых
предпринимателей особенно стартапе в it
сфере и они просят у меня инвестиций
Каждый раз когда они просят у меня
инвестиций они мне показывают графики
где вот у них рост был такой такой потом
вот здесь я инвестирую и у них рост
начинается Вот так я всегда Смеюсь и
говорю А почему вот рост должен быть
после меня нельзя сделать так чтобы был
рост до меня чтобы вот вы вот так шли
вот так начали расти А потом только я
инвестирую на что они тоже смеются и
говорят нет мы ваши деньги будем
использовать мы потратим на маркетинг мы
снизим цену мы порвём конкурентов и так
далее и так далее и В таких случаях Я
говорю Вы знаете я вот прямо кожей
чувствую что в это же самое время ваши
конкуренты сидят где-то с другими
инвесторами и и рассказывают то же самое
и из-за того что вы все хотите это
сделать в результате ваши усилия просто
взаимо погашаются и это
происходит потому что вы не учитываете
действие внешних сил вы думаете что вы
живёте в вакууме поэтому для того чтобы
не тратить зря силы Вы должны чётко
понимать когда что-то планируете какие
будут силы противодействия какие будут
силы содействия И какие силы
взаимодействия которые вы должны
перетянуть на свою сторону Поэтому
всегда учитывайте эти три силы при
постановке цели и до того как вы начнёте
вообще двигаться к ней вторая очень
важная вещь при стремлении или движении
к цели которые вы должны учитывать это
учёт внешних сил К сожалению многие люди
не учитывают эту составляющую А это
наверно самое важное в достижении целей
представим Давайте такую ситуацию Когда
вы плывёте на реке а один гребёт против
течения работает день и ночь 24 на 7 и
стоит на месте другой не гребёт но встал
не на то течение и его вообще отнесло в
другую сторону а третий вы сидите в
лодке и гребёт только тогда когда
необходимо для того чтобы поймать
правильное течение так вот если взять
весь его путь до его цели Как вы думаете
Сколько времени он работает как правило
он работает не более 20% времени
80% Времени или
80% энергии а при достижении цели тратит
внешние силы он использует внешние силы
он использует не свои силы а силы
которые ему помогают или силы содействия
поэтому очень важно Вот это помнить ээ и
использовать при движении к своей цели
Ну или возьмём например другой пример
возьмём пример с рыбалкой один а Рыбак
например пришёл забросил удочку и сидит
Он просто как бы рыбачит на удачу другой
Рыбак пришёл закинул пять удочек с
разными насадками и так далее У него
шансов больше а третий Рыбак всё изучил
погоду давление он чётко понимает на
какую рыбу он рыбачит он знает как Какую
насадку эта рыба любит и он пришёл в тот
водоём где полно этой рыбы Как вы
думаете у кого больше шансов конечно же
у третьего человека Почему Потому что он
пришёл он идёт к своей цели с учётом
внешних обстоятельств для него его
работу выполняет 80% как минимум внешние
обстоятельства что он делает он только
берёт удочку насадку правильно
насаживает кидает и сидит ждёт всё ведь
остальное делает внешние сил поэтому
нельзя а двигаться к цели без учёта
внешних сил и без учёта внешних
обстоятельств Поверьте мне вы потратите
кучу энергии кучу сил на то чтобы
преодолевать внешнее сопротивление для
того чтобы прийти к этому я потратил
годы жизни совершил огромное количество
ошибок для того чтобы прийти к этим
истинам А подскажите как этот принцип
внешних сил научиться находить вот в
обычных целях Например у меня задача
построить свой загородный дом для семьи
Как я могу здесь вот научиться видеть
внешние силы какие они могут быть Ну
например вы хотите построить себе
загородный дом Какие могут быть силы
противодействия прежде всего нужно
начать с них потому что они А на виду и
их легко увидеть смотря где вы хотите
построить вы хотите если там рядом с
национальным парком или в какой-то
экологически чистой зоне то понятно что
скорее всего там будут какие-то экологи
активисты который будут против вас это
могут быть какие-то соседи которые не
хотят чтобы рядом кто-то строился в то
же время у вас есть сила содействия Ну
понятно Это ваша семья это городские
власти которые может быть хотят чтобы вы
там благоустрой или в тот район и так
далее это могут
быть сотрудники Если вы там им
предложили вместе строить коттеджный
посёлок либо дольщики которые готовы
вместе с вами там что-то строить
развивать и так далее ну и в то же время
у вас есть силы взаимодействие это куча
людей которые нейтрально на это смотрят
это может быть те же подписчики в
социальных сетях Где вы просто
показываете свой проект показывайте
выгоды этого проекта и всячески
Старайтесь переманить общественное
мнение на на свою сторону благодаря тому
что у вас есть силы содействия и силы
взаимодействия
которая за вас готовы заступиться за вас
и которые готовы защищать Этот проект А
вам легче будет преодолевать все
сопротивления Более того я вам так скажу
это из трактата об искусстве войны сузы
а там есть классная фраза где говорится
плох тот генерал который побеждает
сражений хорош тот генерал который
побеждает без сражений То есть вы должны
на свою сторону привлечь такие силы при
которых сражение с вами теряет смысл и
силы противодействия просто сдаются это
вы знаете как в физике или я не знаю
наверное в сопротивлении материалов есть
такое понятие как точка перелома Когда
вы берёте металл его гнёт гнёт гнёт гнёт
гнёт он сопротивляется сопротивляется
сопротивляется потом в какой-то момент
тых и всё легко пошло вот важно Когда вы
двигаетесь к цели а иметь на своей
стороне столько сил которые обеспечивает
вам вот эту точку перелома при котором
ваши конкуренты и ваши враги или
недоброжелательный
недоброжелательный просто предпочитают
не бороться Вот это самое идеальное
состояние использования внешних сил А
если вы будете всё делать Через силу
Особенно это плохо когда вы не
учитываете все эти весь этот расклад
внешних сил Когда вы боретесь это просто
как белка в колесе ты целый день
борешься а как головы Змея Горыныча
проблемы растут и растут растут и растут
проблемы Ты одну голову Срубил выросло
две новых это к сожалению то чем
занимается большинство людей и Корневая
причина в том что они начали своё дело
без учёта внешних сил А я уверен у
каждого человека в жизни были такие
ситуации когда какие-то дела у вас вот
так происходили по щелчку пальцев А
какие-то дела которые вы например
считаете важными Может быть вы просто
Паши Паши боритесь сопротивляйтесь это
даётся с таким тяжёлым трудом э и вы не
понимаете почему так происходит у меня к
сожалению в жизни тоже было много таких
случаев и я за собой заметил когда я
анализировал весь свой прошлый опыт
заметил что именно там где я учитывал
внешние силы у меня всё происходило
легко играючи и у меня даже было такое
ощущение Вот таких лёгких денег а на
самом деле они нелёгкие количество
энергии которое было потрачено на то
чтобы заработать их было такое же просто
большую часть работы выполнял не я а
внешней силой А вас я прошу Вы
расскажите в комментариях о своих
историях Будет очень интересно почитать
и Давайте пообсуждали там основная идея
моего этого видео заключается в том
чтобы обратить Ваше внимание и ваш фокус
именно на вот эти вещи и для того чтобы
чётко различать их в своей жизни вам
нужна определённая насмотренность
поэтому об почитайте комментарии
посмотрите как это происходило у других
людей и вы увидите Какие силы бывают
силы противодействия Какие бывают силы
содействия и как можно их использовать в
свою пользу а теперь возникает вопрос А
как правильно нужно действовать чтобы
достигать своих целей так вот для того
чтобы достигать своих целей Прежде всего
прежде всего номер один что Вы должны
сделать это исправить своё намерение или
определить своё намерение Проблема в том
что многие люди ставят себе цель но не
определяют намерение А что такое
намерение намерение - это декларация
всевышнему о ваших истинных целях
смотрите бывает когда вы ставите цель
бывает цель
а ту которую вы декларируется внешне а
бывает та цель которую вы внутри себя
преследуете так вот намерение - это про
внутреннюю цель про то что вы в
действительности хотите Почему намерение
имеет такую вот важность Дело в том что
присти же какой-либо
цели очень важно чтобы у вас было полное
согласие между вашим рациональным мозгом
и вашим подсознанием если не будет
согласия между вашим рациональным мозгом
и подсознанием то вероятность достижения
цели практически равна нули нулю потому
что ваше подсознание превращается в силу
противодействия помните то о чём я и
говорил вот эти силы содействия
противодействия и взаимодействия они
происходят не только во внешнем мире они
происходят и внутри вас поэтому когда
ставите цель обязательно поставьте своё
намерение пропишите своё намерение
например в моей практике Я заметил такую
вещь Вы знаете я занимаюсь
образовательной платформой Я заметил
такую вещь что когда у нас показатели
начали падать я пришёл в компанию и
своему исполнительному директору говорю
Смотри надо нам исправить намерение мы
где-то отошли от пути наше намерение и
моё намерение всё время было так обучать
людей и благодаря этому зарабатывать но
в какой-то момент
мы начали отходить от курса и начали
зарабатывать деньги на обучении А это
совсем другое одно дело обучать людей и
на этом благодаря этому зарабатывать а
другое дело зарабатывать на обучении
намерение - это то что говорит вам Куда
направлена ваша душа Если ваше намерение
обучать людей и благодаря этому
зарабатывать то ваша душа все ваши фибры
Вашей души направлены на обучение а если
ваше намерение зарабатывать на обучении
то все ваши фибры направлены только на
деньги и ни слова о людях ну и
соответственно формируется ваше
поведение поэтому любое ваше действие
если в нём будет неправильное намерение
то Поверьте мне у вас не будет ни
повторных покупок ни постоянных клиентов
ни лояльных клиентов и
неудовлетворённости у клиентов тоже не
будет Поэтому прежде всего прежде чем
достигать любой цели Напишите на бумажке
Какое у вас истинное намерение Это
первый момент второй момент после того
как вы определили своё истинное
намерение нужно произвести учёт внешних
сил задав себе три вопроса Первый
вопрос Правильное ли это время для того
чтобы это делать если мы вспомним про
рыбака то идти в обед наверное не самая
лучшая идея рыба обычно клюёт либо утром
либо вечером Поэтому нужно задать себе
вопрос правильно Правильное ли это время
для того чтобы это делать это касается
не только рыбалки это касается всего в
жизни второй вопрос в правильном ли
месте я нахожусь для этого действия это
если мы вернёмся к рыбалке
то правильное место определяется
наличием водоёма с рыбой в правильном ли
месте в клёво ли месте я нахожусь и
третий вопрос который вы должны задать
себе складываются ли обстоятельства в
мою пользу если мы возьмём пример с
рыбалкой то надо посмотреть берег
водоёма есть ли там удобные
подходы как вообще погода в твою пользу
или нет ветер и так далее и так далее и
в жизни тоже вы можете посмотреть на
настроение общества посмотреть Куда В
целом политика идёт и так далее и с
учётом этих всех обстоятельств можете
понять что в вашу сторону обстоятельства
складываются или нет Поэтому после того
как Вы определились с намерением вам
нужно чётко понять В какую сторону
работают внеш силы путём задавания трёх
вопросов и после того как вы определили
вот эту вторую часть учёт внешних сил
вот тогда наступает время для
составления плана и этот план он
учитывает первое ваши намерения второе
учёт внешних сил и третье Ваши действия
И после этого пожалуйста действуйте и Да
прибудет с вами удача Все лайфхаки и
свои знания которые я почерпнул из
своего опыта
о том как эффективно достигать своих
целей я обычно даю в телеграме поэтому
переходите по ссылке внизу И самое
главное не забывайте такие вещи что мы
не живём в вакууме Мы живём в динамичной
среде Мы живём в обществе общество - это
совокупность всех людей у которых есть
свои желания свои хотелки они у них свои
цели они тоже двигаются к своим целям и
ваша задача не бороться с ними поэтому
помните Вы живёте не в вакууме второе
помните что самая главная внешняя сила в
этом мире - это Всевышний поэтому
Исправьте своё намерение или пропишите
своё истинное намерение потому что вы
будете достигать именно своего истинного
намерения а не своих целей важно чтобы
ваши намерения и цели совпадали и третий
момент обязательно учитывайте внешние
силы потому что без учёта внешних сил вы
просто будете грести д 4 на 7 против
течения и после этого уже составляйте
план и действуйте на здоровье Удачи вам
и счастливой жизни